antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et bienvenue sur
le plateau d'antenne de nouveau mardi
noir à la bourse de paris moins 6%
aujourd'hui en clôture les crises
boursières et monétaires débouche sur
une crise de confiance pour la première
fois les petits porteurs ont craqué nous
les écouterons dans quelques minutes
malaise après la suspension de
l'instruction de l'affairé michel droit
alors que les juges d'instruction
affirment leur solidarité
la cour de cassation se dit victime
d'une campagne de discrédit dépister au
plus tôt les troubles de la vue pour
mieux les corriger désormais les moyens
existent pour un diagnostic précoce dès
les premiers mois du nourrisson
le sommet arabe dahmane dominée par la
spectaculaire accolade entre le syrien
assad et l'irakien saddam hussein mais
on s'interroge déjà sur la pérennité de
la réconciliation
un petit nouveau de 101 kg dans le
quinze de france carl janyk troisième
ligne et capitaine du stade toulousain
fera ses premières armes internationale
demain contre la roumanie
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés sur les marchés
financiers les jours se suivent et se
ressemblent mais il faut bien
reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui le choc est
encore plus difficile à amortir que
d'habitude
- 6 0 4% à la bourse de paris un dollar
qui poursuit sa glissade et un franc qui
résistent difficilement face aux
différentes monnaies notamment face aux
d'autres marques
aujourd'hui à la bourre certaines
valeurs ont été quasiment brader entre
guillemets c'est le cas des piliers du
marché comme peugeot la compagnie du
midi ou encore le groupe thomson csf
plus grave encore les petits porteurs
visiblement impressionné par la décote
du groupe suez d'hier ont craqué pour la
toute première fois
bilan nouvelle journée noire et des
espoirs qui s'envole patrick boitet
encore une séance noire à la bourse de
paris
la quatrième depuis le début de la crise
aujourd'hui en moyenne les valeurs
françaises ont abandonné 6% et parfois
plus du double pour des piliers du
marché comme peugeot bongrain courroucé
l'ucla on constate le même phénomène sur
d'autres places financières comme
francfort zurich ou londres et le manque
de conservation international n'arrange
rien les ordres de ventes viennent de
partout des gros investisseurs français
et surtout étrangers comme les allemands
mais aussi pour la première fois des
particuliers qui craque
après des semaines d'inquiétude
manque de chance pour la dernière
privatiser suez mise en vente à 317
francs le titre a déjà perdu en 2 jours
20 % même si du côté des professionnels
on assure que dans la situation actuelle
cela aurait pu être pire l'action suez a
moins baissé que que le reste du marché
qu'en tout cas il avait à ses côtés
depuis plusieurs semaines elle aurait
baissé davantage
par conséquent c'est une satisfaction
relative c'est quand même une
satisfaction
piètre consolation pour les petits
porteurs
ceux qui possèdent dix actions suez
enquête aujourd'hui une perte sèche de 6
ans l'enfant difficile à avaler quand la
publicité promettait monts et merveilles
une toute nouvelle association sos
petits porteurs réclame aujourd'hui
l'établissement d'un prix plancher pour
les privatiser le seul moyen selon elle
de prévenir une panique généralisée
je crois que les gars du port public ont
intérêt à prendre très au sérieux la
colère qui commence à monter chez les
petits porteurs d'abord parce qu'ils
risquent de déserter la bourse ce qui
risquerait citoyens pour une véritable
catastrophe boursière
d'autre part également en raison des
risques politiques que ça comporte à
l'heure actuelle toutes les
introductions en bourse se trouve
stopper une société aussi prestigieuse
qui le saint laurent une charge aussi
connu que tu fais chier préfère attendre
des jours plus favorable du côté
dénationaliser officiellement rien n'est
remis en cause mais la mise en vente de
matra est stoppée sans parler du gros
morceau lui ap les milieux financiers
considère que sa privatisation de
décembre est fortement compromise ce
serait pour l'état un manque à gagner de
25 milliards de francs ou ce qui est
grave aujourd'hui philippe sassier c'est
que les crises boursières et monétaires
font place à une véritable crise de
confiance les incertitudes engendre de
l'inquiétude trois semaines après le
premier lundi noir de wall street on
s'aperçoit qu'on discute toujours à
washington pour savoir comment on va
diminuer le déficit budgétaire américain
ce matin francfort perd des 10% la
glissade du dollar paraissait
inarrêtable break avait beaucoup
d'inquiétudes et on se demandait quand
quand les pays occidentaux allaient
finir par se rencontrer sous est
toujours dans le rouge 1 696 1000 titres
échangés aujourd'hui l'hémorragie
continue pas c'est vrai que pas
seulement sur ce nom susan boyle 2%
aujourd'hui on va c'est vrai que pour la
première fois certains petits porteurs
ont craqué
on est dans le domaine de l'irrationnel
parce que quand on voit un titre comme
peugeot perdre 15% alors que l'industrie
automobile française annonce un boom de
ces ventes on voit qu'aujourd'hui
l'économie n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec la finance en tout cas il ya
quelques raisons d'espérer peut-être ce
soir il y eut quelques rachats et puis
londres qui baissaient fortement a
terminé en hausse et puis la déclaration
du président ian qui vient d'annoncer
qu'il ne souhaitait pas une nouvelle
baisse du dollar est ce que ça peu sur
le fond changer telle que je souhaitais
était là la bonne surprise de cette fin
de journée parce que ça a stoppé
justement la glissade du dollar c'est
assez étonnant parce qu'on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à ce qu'une
déclaration du président disait mais des
états unis parviennent à arrêter la
chute du dollar le dollar qui côté
jusqu'à 5 françois s'en tient à new york
qui remonte à cinq francs 68 il cotait 1
map récente quatre ils viennent de
remonter à plus de 1 marque 67 wall
street qui perdait 50 points est en
train de remonter mais en tout cas ce ne
sont pas des petites phrases qui
révéleront la confiance en tout cas on
sent que le marché s'est peut être
important sans que le marché est prêt à
accueillir et à réagir une bonne
nouvelle ça peut indiquer un changement
la cause petite note d'espoir peut-être
hull qui critiquent la justice malade la
cour de cassation en crise depuis
quelques jours l'intrusion de la
politique sur le terrain des affaires
judiciaires débouche sur un malaise
apparemment le dessaisissement
provisoire du juge grelier dans la
sphère droit cncl est la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase
hier les juges d'instruction ont exprimé
leur solidarité avec leurs confrères
grelier
aujourd'hui les magistrats de la cour de
cassation se sont réunis en assemblée
extraordinaire afin de dissiper tout
malentendu tâche difficile ponctuée d'un
mot indignation commentaire de dominique
verdeilhan et patrice pollet tension
atmosphère de crise
ce matin les magistrats de la cour de
cassation passe devant les caméras sans
anne simone rozès premier président de
la cour les a convoqués à l'assemblée
générale
motif de cette réunion répondre aux
attaques dont la cour est l'objet dans
la sphère michel droit
michel droit qui le 27 octobre est
inculpé de forfaiture par le juge
grelier dans le cadre de l'attribution
d'une fréquence sur la bande fm
trois jours plus tard michel droit
introduit une requête en suspicion
légitime et l'instruction du juge
grelier est suspendu jusqu'en d'essence
vendredi dernier coup de colère de
pierre arpaillange procureur général de
la cour de cassation pour lui des
pressions considérables ont été exercés
dans cette affaire ils s'inquiètent je
cite que les juges en soit réduit au
rôle de bouffon de la république et
qu'ils soient combattues et injurié par
des gens qui n'ont peut-être pas le même
amour de la justice et le même
désintéressement
après ce coup d'éclat du procureur
pierre arpaillange ce matin à l'issue de
trois heures de réunion à huis clos
simone rozès met en accusation la presse
alors la cour de cassation a pris
connaissance avec indignation de la
campagne intolérable et partisane qui
s'est développée dans certains journaux
et qui tendent à jeter le discrédit sur
ses décisions et exercer une pression
inadmissible sur le cours de la justice
s'interdisant de polémique
elle continuera avec son coeur sa
mission dans l'indépendance et la
sérénité
point final quant au juge d'instruction
par la bouche d'alain saurait leur doyen
il faisait savoir dès hier soir qu'ils
étaient solidaires du juge grelier et
que cette affaire se plaçait sur le
terrain d'un enjeu politique
oui jérôme kamini quelques heures après
la réunion extraordinaire de la cour de
cassation on a l'impression que la
montagne a accouché d'une souris
et oui en sept lignes d'un cour de
cassation a tout dit trois heures et
demie de discussions pour aboutir un
communiqué madame simone rozès le
premier personnage de cette haute
juridiction s'en prend à certains
journaux lisez entre les lignes
les quotidiens le matin et le monde
toute cette affaire se développe dans un
double contexte d'une part la suspension
de l'instruction par le juge grelier
dans la sphère michel droit et d'autre
part la réforme de l'instruction entamée
par monsieur robert badinter est reprise
par l'actuelle garde des sceaux monsieur
chalandon à l'instant même où le dossier
de michel droit échappé à claude burlier
la plupart des juges se sont sentis
dépossédés des juges d'instruction ont
le sentiment que dans la sphère michel
droit la cour de cassation a cédé à des
pressions
éthique certains le disent ouvertement
le doyen des juges alain sauret
considère que la sphère grelier a dérapé
sur le terrain d'un enjeu un enjeu
politique bien sûr
sous-entendu le gouvernement intervient
plus ou moins directement sur le terrain
des affaires judiciaires
un terrain qui ne devrait pas le
concerner premières réactions celle du
procureur général arpaillange et il le
dit dans la presse il met l'accent sur
la menace qui pèse sur les juges leur
pouvoir vite il risque d'être paralysée
jusqu'ici on reproche au procureur en
pariant d'avoir manqué à son droit de
réserve
la réaction de madame rozès ne s'adresse
pas directement au juge mais à ceux qui
utilisent la presse comme caisse de
résonance
en fait les juges ont le sentiment que
ce qui arrive à leurs confrères grelier
peut arriver demain à chacun d'entre eux
dans le passé
les juges se sont déjà heurtées au
pouvoir politique mais ce double guy m'a
donc parions la sphère grelier et les
réformes de l'instruction risque
d'entamer la fonction des juges et cela
il ne le tolère pas merci et des juges
décidément sur la sellette hier en
italie le pouvoir des juges étaient
soumis à référendum les italiens se sont
prononcés pour la responsabilité civile
des juges
en d'autres termes les juges devront
payer en cas d'erreur marcel trillât
c'est un peu comme si on avait demandé
aux italiens
est ce que vous détestez les juges oui
ou non évidemment 80% d'entre eux ont
répondu oui
les juges devront donc payer de leur
poche des dommages et intérêts pour
toute erreur commise au détriment d'un
prévenu ils sont insupportables il est
vrai ses juges tout puissant
théoriquement indépendant de tout
pouvoir et à qui il arrive parfois le
jeter en prison des innocents pour des
années bien sûr ils ont souvent payé le
prix du sang dans leur combat efficace
contre les tueurs des brigades rouges et
contre les parrains de la mafia et tout
cela est bien loin déjà et puis ce sont
les risques du métier
depuis les petits juges sont mis en tête
de s'attaquer aux scandales qui
éclaboussent souvent les partis
politiques italiens ils n'hésitent plus
à traiter comme des malfaiteurs les
puissants comme s'ils me donnent à calvi
ou jelly et les politiciens véreux pris
la main dans le sac
dorénavant il y regarderont sans doute à
deux fois avant d'accuser un banquier ou
un honoré voler comme on dit ici hein
honorables députés une seule parade déjà
envisagé par les juges les assurances
elles permettront peut-être à ses
fonctionnaires notoirement mal payés de
continuer à mettre leur nez où il ne
faudrait pas sans risque et à chaque
fois la soupe populaire justice encore
on vient d'apprendre que la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de paris
a refusé aujourd'hui une demande de mise
en liberté des frères chômé et joaillier
jacques et pierre chaumet sont
incarcérés pour banqueroute abus de
confiance et escroquerie depuis le 13
juin dernier
on enchaîne avec une information qui ne
laissera pas insensibles monde
judiciaire jacques hiver et deux
complices se sont évadés aujourd'hui de
la centrale de saint-maur dans le
département de l'indre
jacky vert s'était illustré il ya
quelques années en kidnappant
souvenez-vous michel maury laribière
l'un des responsables du cnpf
aujourd'hui son évasion sort de
l'ordinaire c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire
roland sicard labels tels que
l'imaginent les scénaristes de cinéma
aujourd'hui en début d'après midi
jacques hiver farid boulard a cp de
colas s'empare de la benne à ordures de
la centrale pénitentiaire de saint maur
près de châteauroux
le conducteur du véhicule ne peut rien
faire pour s'interposer
ma droite vers la porte et m'a dit
dessins de l'ada deux autres le passé
aux côtés m'ont pris par le cou je suis
par terre montée en gamme et où ils sont
partis ils étaient armés
non et la rend si vous êtes retourné
vous les avez vu qu'ils font c'est avec
une benne avec babel la partie dans la
porte des cuisines et de rentrer en
marche arrière de la défense et la prof
compression partie des trois évadés
jacques hiver est de loin le plus connu
en 1980 il avait organisé l'enlèvement
de michel maury laribière alors vice
président du patronat français michel
maury laribière avait été détenu pendant
11 jours avant d'être libéré sans
qu'aucune rançon ne soit versée ce soir
le plan filets bleus a été mise en place
dans la région de châteauroux les
enquêteurs tentent de trouver lundi ce
qui pourrait les mettre sur la piste de
jacques hiver et de ses complices
politique devant les élus du parti
républicain en toi léotard a confirmé ce
matin sa décision de s'occuper lui-même
du dossier des élections
comme prévu françois léotard reprend
donc à michel d'ornano le dossier des
élections législatives mais il se défend
par la même occasion de vouloir éliminer
le courant giscardien il n'empêche que
la décision provoque quelques remous au
sein de la
famille libérale notamment chez les amis
de l'ancien président de la république
olivier lerner bonjour comment ça va
pour le p r ça va très bien pour le père
je n'ai rien avec silver nano quel est
le climat très bon très bon vous avez
mis un certain nombre de choses à plat
ce matin fait pratiquement tous un petit
déjeuner à huis clos pour laver son
linge sale en famille un petit déjeuner
pour recoller les pots cassés mais entre
deux portes
on l'entendra françois léotard confirmé
sans regret sa décision de reprendre à
michel d'ornano le dossier des élections
le patron a ses têtes le patron n'en
fait qu'à sa tête bon je suis dessaisi
du dossier par conséquent c'est une
affaire qui est de me concerne plus en
ce qui concerne l'organisation
il ya juste deux choses que j'ai à dire
effectivement ça posait un problème
politique et puis il faut voir comment
sera l'organisation future pour le parti
c'est tout nous avons bien entendu
souligné au secrétaire-général tout
l'effort qui a été fait par notre ami
michel d'ornano dans l'exercice de
fonctions qu'il a eu et aujourd'hui le
secrétaire général dit qu'il veut
prendre en main et le dossier des
élections le voeu des parlementaires ce
qu'il le fasse aussi bien que ce que
l'afld et michel d'ornano
aujourd'hui la bande à léo boitille les
giscardiens du p r sont furieux michel
d'ornano digère mal cette mise à l'écart
mais les hôtes indiens du p r sont
inquiets troublés par cette affaire et
les barriste du p r compte les points
trois courants pour un patron trois
courants pour un parti le parti
républicain sera désormais bien
difficile à gérer avant pendant et après
les présidentielles à l'étranger la
syrie et l'irak réconcilier au sommet du
monde arabe à amman c'est
incontestablement un succès éclatant
pour le roi hussein de jordanie
car les deux hommes étaient brouillés
depuis plus de huit ans officiellement
on parle d'une réconciliation importante
car elle ouvre la voie à une position
commune du monde arabe face au conflit
en irak
il n'empêche il n'empêche que ces
retrouvailles n'ont pas convaincu tout
le monde
peu de commentaires à damas où les
médias sont d'une étonnante discrétion
pas d'enthousiasmé forcené à amman où
certains évoquent une réconciliation de
façade
jean-marc il use heureux le roi hussein
un an de médiation fébrile lui a donc
permis de faire hier
rahman un petit miracle en obtenant que
les frères ennemis syrien et irakien se
donnent l'accolade
loin des caméras mais devant les chefs
d'état et de délégations de 20 pays
arabes
obsédé par le danger que fait planer sur
nombre d'entre eux la guerre iran irak
retrouvailles de chefs d'état mais pas
encore de réconciliation politique
le terme est jugée prématurée par la
syrie ce soir la syrie qui reste l'allié
de l'iran et garde son rôle
d'intermédiaire courtisé entre arabes et
perses
c'est vrai l'accolade d'allemagne aura
certainement levé un tabou car sans
accord entre ses lignes irak
pas de position arabe commune possible
face à l'iran bouffée d'optimisme donc
mais optimisme prudent
personne ne se cache qu'il sera bien
difficile le monde arabe de transformer
l'essai marqué hier soir à amman en un
accord durable à paris suite du voyage
du président chinois monsieur lyrks xiam
nan
aujourd'hui au quai d'orsay la france et
la chine ont signé un protocole
financier pour 87 d'un montant de 747
millions de dollars le protocole porte
sur le financement par la france de
trois projets industriels en chine
notamment une centrale thermique et une
usine d'engrais qu signatures
importantes car la france n'est plus
actuellement que le onzième partenaire
commercial de la chine
très loin derrière des voisins européens
comme la rfa l'italie et la grande
bretagne
le marché chinois que les français
tentent de conquérir offre des
possibilités exceptionnelles d'autant
que la consommation en chine connaît un
développement sans précédent surtout sur
le marché libre en quête de christian
giroux et claude hudelot
changsha au coeur de la chine un million
d'habitants une bille moyenne dans un
marché libre où les paysans viennent
vendre directement leurs produits
un marché très actif ou madame song
notre interprète est venu lui faire ses
achats du chou d'abord
la montagne ça coûte combien 3 sam dim
de la viande ensuite
c'est presque le salaire de votre
journée ça mais c'est sert effectivement
madame se gagnent 100 yuans par mois
soit environ 200 francs non comprises
les primes nettement moins que les
paysans qui vendent par exemple de3
france philo tout juste ce que madame se
gagne dans sa journée produits chers les
oeufs sont d'abord réservé aux enfants
il rapporte gros le chiffre d'affaires
de ce paysan approche 1800 francs par
mois
c'est considérable avec mon argent je
peux m'acheter des choses nécessaires et
je vais pouvoir me faire construire une
maison
même son gâchettes du poisson un franc
52 kg le paysan en vend 50 kg par jour
chiffre d'affaires plus de 2000 francs
par mois
à l'évidence le problème numéro 1 en
chine et l'augmentation des prix
l'appelation s'élève officiellement à 6%
mais les produits alimentaires semblent
évoluer beaucoup plus vite
une chose est sûre il est difficile de
libérer les marchés et de contrôle et en
même temps les prix regain de tension au
bangladesh ce matin à dacca la police a
tiré sur les manifestants bilan quatre
morts et plusieurs blessés l'opposition
affiche des chiffres beaucoup plus lourd
et parle de 14 morts les manifestants
réclamaient la démission du gouvernement
et du président au pouvoir depuis six
ans le général ershad doit faire face à
une épreuve de force sans précédent
entretenue par une opposition plus unis
que jamais reportage de geneviève moll
les événements d'aujourd'hui se prépare
à dacca depuis plusieurs semaines chaque
jour dans tout le pays
défi des meetings se sont succédé avec
pour but la mobilisation d'aujourd'hui
dans la capitale pour exiger le départ
de l'actuel président feu scène indé
rade à la tête du pays depuis six ans et
que l'opposition accuse de corruption et
d'entraîner le bangladesh à sa perte
face à mohammad arshad deux femmes
chaque racine à la fille du premier
président du bangladesh mujibur rahman
assassiné dans cette maison en 75 et la
bégum khaleda zia la femme du précédent
président tué lui en 80 c'est la
coalition des veuves qui a eu lieu
officiellement la semaine dernière pour
faire cesser une situation que le juge
intolérable car le bangladesh ses 110
millions d'habitants entassés sur un
territoire qui ne représente que le
quart de la france c'est un pays
agricole mais 60% des paysans sans terre
c'est l'un des pays les plus pauvres du
monde revenu moyen 720 francs par an et
par habitant
le bangladesh avait essentiellement de
l'aide internationale dispensés par la
banque mondiale et par plus de 250
organisations non gouvernementales les
fameuses ong mélèzes n'atteint pas
toujours les plus démunis et les poches
de pauvreté subsiste partout à dakar un
quart de la population vit dans des
bidonvilles la natalité est de 2,8 pour
cent mais 130 à 140 enfants pour 1000
meurent avant cinq ans c'est contre tout
cela contre une inflation de 20% par an
contre une économie tenus par des
groupes de pression souper les ouvriers
contre une corruption généralisée que
s'élèvent aujourd'hui l'opposition et
selon cheikh hasina
le mouvement ne fait que commencer si le
président ne s'en va pas qu'allez vous
faire
nous continuerons nous voulons une
constitution dont la démocratie nous
allons continuer
pour le pape est avec nous les autres
nouvelles de l'étranger en bref ensuite
on parle médecine et sport avec jean ma
mère
j'ai re perd son président ceni kountché
l'homme qui avait échappé à trois coups
d'état a succombé aujourd'hui à une
longue maladie il était hospitalisé à
paris
en 13 ans pouvoir il avait réussi à
stabiliser son pays l'un des plus
pauvres du monde
son plus fidèle ami le colonel ali ces
bus assure le pouvoir par intérim
le journaliste français allain guillot
sera jugée à kaboul où il est emprisonné
depuis un mois un avertissement lancé
aux journalistes qui accompagnent la
résistance afghane dans cette affaire
l'union soviétique a un rôle à jouer
estime le quai d'orsay
l'attentât de colombo n'a toujours pas
été revendiqué une bombe cachée dans un
autobus a tué hier au moins 32 personnes
dont une dizaine d'enfants les autorités
retiennent de piste les rebelles tamouls
et les marxistes cinghalais jvp
clandestins la mort par amour et par le
feu à 22 ans cette jeune femme s'est
immolée sur le bûcher de son mari décédé
contre cette tradition religieuse
interdite par la loi des centaines de
fans viennent protester tiers à new
delhi elles ont demandé au gouvernement
d'intervenir pour empêcher une telle
pratique
l'europe et la médecine font bon ménage
ouverture aujourd'hui à montpellier
d'euromédecine en façade 600 chercheurs
face à douze mille médecins dans les
dossiers des révélations étonnantes on
appris aujourd'hui et ce n'est là qu'un
exemple que dès les premières semaines
de la vie on pouvait détecter chez un
tout petit bébé
les défauts de vision plus
révolutionnaire encore les enfants
peuvent porter des lentilles de contact
j'ai bien dit des lentilles de contact
dès le plus jeune âge
reportage de daniel duigou dès la
naissance l'enfant regarde avec ses
grands yeux il est curieux il veut
comprendre mais encore faut-il qu'ils
puissent voir
or tous les bébés ne voit pas bien à
deux ans déjà 16 à 20% d'entre eux ont
des troubles de la vision
pour beaucoup c'est déjà trop tard les
conséquences peuvent être graves
même pour de simples myopie il faut
savoir que ces défauts optiques peuvent
retarder le développement intellectuel
de l'enfant s'ils ne sont pas corrigés
suffisamment tôt mais surtout qu'ils
peuvent entraîner par exemple un
strabisme l'enfant se met à loucher est
alors l'enfant ne regarde qu'avec un
seul oeil et l'autre oeil devient
paresseux nous disons nous qu'il devient
en biop si on ne corrige pas
suffisamment tôt cet enfant c'est en bio
pis peut-être définitive et l'enfant
perd la vision cet oeil pour le restant
de ses jours
deux petites électrodes placées au
niveau des tentes
elles vont permettre de dépister un
défaut de vision le bébé est placé en
face d'un écran sur lequel se déplace
une mire
un peu plus loin grâce à un ordinateur
le médecin suit le tracé du regard de
l'enfant qui normalement doit suivre le
mouvement de la mire
dès qu'un trouble et identifiants
corrige le défaut avec des lentilles
même taille que celle des adultes
elle se porte en permanence même la nuit
mais ce n'est pas toujours facile de les
lui m ça devrait être obligatoire
d'avoir préparé un examen approfondi
pour savoir si oui ou non il faut il
faut pas corriger la vue c'est très
important de savoir qu'à six ans il est
trop tard quand cet été à l'école c'est
vraiment trop tard
ok sur sa pose quelques problèmes de
comme l'abattage anti ca c saf à ces
peurs nos vérités c'est très facile
rappelons un premier dépistage peut être
pratiqué par les parents comme le feu
ici le médecin en jouant avec l'enfant
il suffit de vérifier qu'il suit bien du
regard un objet qu'on déplace devant lui
on cache un oeil puis l'autre pour
comparer et dès le moindre doute il est
prudent de consulter un pédiatre c'est
bien tu as été très sage oui regarde et
kiev voilà si vos bébés préfère des
lunettes c'est bien leurs droits il ya
aussi ça il paraît que c'est sympa et
puis ça donne un petit air
intellectuelle le sport antenne de
chaînes du rugby diffusera demain à
14h30 le match france roumanie
traditionnellement france roumanie c'est
le match test avant le tournoi des six
nations mais cette année c'est surtout
le premier match après la coupe du monde
jean ma mère en vain grande rentrée dans
le bilan international
alors malgré les blessures jacques
fouroux n'a pris aucun risque une seule
grande innovation dans un équipe
l'entrée de carl janyk le toulousain le
décathlonien du rugby il ya longtemps
que la porte l'équipe de france était
entrouverte
elle s'ouvre définitivement reportage de
thierry blancot quand j'allume 27 ans 1
m 89 fins utiles aux passions
rugby jusqu'au bout des doigts et
pourtant c'est par l'athlétisme qu'il a
commencé car le génie avec une
spécialité le disque trois records de
france avant de tâter gabarit oblige du
ballon ovale deux fois champion de
france avec le stade toulousain dont il
est aujourd'hui le capitaine carles
janyk prototype même du troisième ligne
moderne tonique et accrocheur car
villepreux trois mots pour définir karl
janyk et bien simplement compétence
courage et certainement une grande envie
de devenir international six ans de
rugby au plus haut niveau les portes du
quinze de france ouverte avec
l'intention d'y rester au niveau des
sélections j'ai su le cours normal des
choses c'est à dire que je suis passé
par les france universitaire france
militaire français à prime france des
jeux me retour en france a aujourd'hui
après effectivement six ans de rugby
les choses sont allées très vite je le
reconnais mais mais peut-être que mes
qualités
on fait que ses cheveux puis ce but
allait vite quoi karl janyk landi star
une volonté à tout casser les roumains
l'ont déjà à l'oeil les sélectionneur du
quinze de france aussi en pensant
pourquoi pas au tournoi des six nations
le cyclisme en deux mots jean ma mère
qu'est ce qu'on apprend jeannie longo
était positive j'allais dire dopé pour
son record du monde à colorado springs
effectivement une dépêche nous apprend
que des traces des figurines ont été
décelées lors d'un contrôle antidopage
cela est datée du 12 septembre dernier
lors du record du monde du 3 km la
contre-expertise s'est également révélée
positive mais il y a un petit problème
qui se pose c'est que dix jours plus
tard elle a battu le record du monde de
l'heure toujours aux états unis
hélas les contrôles ont été négatifs on
en sort un petit peu plus dans les jours
qui viennent marie-josée des josé plutôt
n'est pas dopée mais il faut du tonus 1
pour donner la météo sur france moment
eh bien demain du soleil pour les
défilés de 11,9 en effet ctive mans il y
aura du soleil le matin de la pluie
l'après midi effectivement un
anticyclone va nous rendre une petite
visite mais une visite éclair comme la
météo ce soir voici donc la zone bleue
que vous voyez sur l'atlantique et bien
correspond assez pause ensoleillée
résultats demain débrouillards surtout
sur le sud ouest et puis place au soleil
et puis dans l'après midi
arrivée d'une perturbation que vous
voyez ici sur le nord-ouest avec ces
nuages et c'est plus du mistral dans le
midi donc un ciel dégagé
les températures 9 degrés dans le nord
10 à lyon et à grenoble et sur la corse
18° demain 11 nouveaux fait ça comme une
sportive
bravo prochain rendez vous d'information
23h30 avec aubry et de l'air demain dès
6h45 n'oubliez pas télématin avec
catherine ceylac roger zabel et marc
hautement à 7h45 l' invité des 4 vérités
sera hubert-curien l'ancien ministre de
la recherche au coeur de l'interview le
programme spatial européen adopté
aujourd'hui
merci d'être fidèle à antenne 2 et à
demain bonsoir